let's go
[Music]
one
[Music]
bang
right out the gate
oh no
that was hey that was 1500. i am
literally right there and i need to that
was online and it like skipped left
but so right now you're at 4 000. yeah
not good enough i can i can do better i
can give you more this is the money bag
you already hit this one money bag okay
[Music]
oh my gosh guys it's okay it's 1 500.
they wind up
oh oh my gosh
you're at 7 000
okay
so
if you hit the inner ring
you hit 8 500 and you tie which is not
what we're looking for but if you make
it in
you go over and the ratings are going up
a hundred percent okay
and no pressure there's more pressure on
me i'll be the one arguing for you we're
just kicking things all right we're just
kicking we're
sixth and final kick put it in the back
of the pool okay
[Music]
oh my gosh guys fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred yeah okay yay that's
fine that's all right the goal the goal
was eighty five hundred we got eighty
five hundred yeah
i'm not gonna lie when i came out here i
was like i don't know if she's getting
four thousand eighty-five thanks for
your trust in me thank you i didn't tell
you until afterwards yeah that's how i'm
a good friend